tombe sur ce message de mon père qui me
dit attention mon fils fusillade dans
les rues de paris etc
et je prends conscience qu'il ya un truc
mais sans voir vraiment réaliser et au
moment où je retourne à ma place je
j'entends des bruits métalliques qui
viennent de du rez de chaussée sans trop
comprendre et en même temps sans trop
réaliser ce qui se passe quand je me
penche voit donc ses trois dimensions
quoi je vois la vue qui s'activent donc
j'imagine extrêmement graphique des
gerbes de sang etc
et la deuxième chose c'est l'odorat donc
je commence à sentir la poudre et en
temps le sent aussi le c6 et inodore qui
les deux sont très métallique donc les
deux mélangés c'est ça prend vraiment au
tricot ac c'est très très violent et une
espèce d'impression de pure n existe à
parcé sont là
pour nous la vie s'arrête à ce moment là
on est vraiment un objet voilà on est on
est réduit à un autre plus simple
personne des êtres humains et on sait
qu'à l'extérieur il ya des tas de choses
qui se passent que la vie continue qui
est un espèce de train qui s'arrêtera
pas qui est en train de tourner à
l'extérieur et il ya des dialogues qui
se lance avec un des négociateurs de la
bri entre le terroriste le plus petit
des deux théories ski qui justement lui
demande des trucs même temps c'est très
brouillon comprend pas et c'est d'un non
sens absolu ou où nous on est passé face
aux fenêtres des otages contre la porte
et on comprend pas comme moi clairement
pendant ces deux heures trente
j'ai pas trop j'ai trouvé aucune
justification à quoi que ce soit et en
même temps j'avais pas envie de le faire
et je pense que c'est humain
je vous retombe sur un autre policier en
haut des escaliers qui mènent sur rez de
chaussée donc on suit le devenir un
objet et on tombe sur un dernier
opérateur qui est au niveau du bar et
jonction de descendre les escaliers et
de voir deux femmes qui s'enlacent et
aux jouets et mon esprit ne refuse de
comprendre et je me dis [ __ ] elles
dorment et en fait elles dorment les
yeux ouverts un dock à son meurtre est
l'opérateur de dire juste après de cette
scène de dire regardez pas je lève les
yeux et en fait derrière lui il ya sept
cette espèce d'amoncellement de cadavres
ou en fait je moi je vois ça je tombe
dans les pommes quoi parce que j'en suis
c'est comme s'il y avait eu un second
traumatisme dans le traumatisme ou je
dis [ __ ] je ne passais deux heures
trente avec les mecs qu'on fait ça et
moi je suis peut marcher j'arrive à
sortir de là les semaines qui ont suivi
le bataclan pour moi retourner dans un
lieu où on fait la fête ou en bois où il
ya de la musique et du rock pour moi le
vrai que voir écouter du rock ça a été
une les preuves absolues c'était
extrêmement difficile de me dire [ __ ]
je vais retourner dans un bar quand je
retournais faire la fête parce que quand
on est barman on participe à la fête on
l'alimenté
d'une certaine façon et moi pour moi la
fête s'était éteinte quoi il ya une
espèce de voile à de fins 13 novembre
ça faisait quatre ou cinq mois que
j'étais avec ma copine à l'époque romane
et ça se passait super bien je sortais
d'une relation qui était un peu un peu
difficiles et j'avais besoin d'un peu de
liberté de renouveau en fait et surtout
j'étais tombé sur une nana un an avant
doris dont j'étais tombé pas amoureux
mais j'avais flashé sur elle quoi après
les attentats contre manne d'argent à
paris je tombe sur une fille qui est
extrêmement touchée est bouleversée par
ce qui m'est arrivé là où moi j'ai
besoin qu'on me soutienne
j'ai l'impression qu'elle a un peu de
mal malheureusement à
à se placer en rock à côté de moi et a
presque à me rassurer quoi et c'est
terrible mais j'ai l'impression que j'ai
pas envie de la rassurer tourisme a été
la preuve rcnm dire on en parle quand tu
veux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
rencontre que je pars et je laisse doriz
et un mois et en fait que doré c'est un
peu comme j'ai dit plus tôt c'est mon
broc est un peu la garante de ma demain
santé mentale malheureusement et ma psy
ne viendra bien sûr après est en fête
j'arrive dans le parc national d'el à
torres del paine et qui sont en fait en
patagonie chilienne et je me retrouve au
milieu de nulle part tout seul
et bien sûr que le l'énorme boulette de
souffrance et de douleur qui me suis
baladée me rattrape à 100% et il me dit
me heurte complètement donc je me
rappelle de d'être dans ma tente
je suis allé me semble à 13 milles 500
km de paris et je vais dire mais qu'est
ce que je fous là quoi donc je vis
vraiment ces deux semaines comme comme
une espèce de deux longs couloirs de
souffrance où j'ai besoin de d'orissa je
l'appelle mais en temps ça capte pas on
a du mal à se parler j'ai pas internet
lancé c'est c'est la cata et un temps ça
me permet de me purger et quand j'arrive
en france je sais que je suis peut-être
prêt à reprendre quelque chose et ce
quelque chose c'est mon quotidien en
fait
le moment où j'ai réussi à faire face
c'était en sortant de chez ma psy en
mars ou en avril 2018 et je sorte sont
eux sont de cette consultation et sans
moi et de me dit bonne route
un truc comme ça et là je me dis ouf là
je suis tout seul et je sais que je fais
armé pour faire face
et pourquoi pas ce que j'ai fait presque
trois ans de thérapie avec elle et que
cam à donner tous les outils nécessaires
pour pour combattre le traumatisme pour
combattre les surgissements de ces
images difficiles et bien sûr qu'il me
restera des douleurs mais bien sûr que
ce sera beaucoup moins dur qu'avant et
que j'aurai la force et la conviction de
me dire que je ne suis je suis plus fort
que ça et que j'arrive à le combattre